what if
we took everything that sustains life on
this planet
and shrunk it down to one small
bubble earth's biosphere
stretches about 20 kilometers from the
deep sea vents in the ocean
into the atmosphere this is where
almost all life exists
if we ever want to live in space or
settle mars we will have to recreate
this
extremely complex system
what would you eat would
you have garbage and
what would be the biggest threat to your
health
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you lived in a closed biosphere
we've tried this once before with
disastrous results
in 1991 eight scientists enclosed
themselves
in a huge research facility called
biosphere 2.
this building was completely shut off
from the outside world
all the food air and water had to be
produced
and recycled within its walls
but the experiment quickly began to fail
there was not enough food or oxygen
the pollinators died and roaches
infested this
mini earth but could we
do it again and this time succeed
the earth's biosphere is technically a
closed system
the only thing that enters the biosphere
is a continuous flow of
energy from the sun but creating an
earth-like biome is not as easy as it
sounds
within earth's biosphere are biomes
communities of flora and fauna that
occupy
major types of habitats you'd need a
collection of biomes to create
a successful life-supporting mini world
like biosphere 2 you'd be living in a 12
700 square meter facility which would
contain a rain forest
an ocean with a coral reef mangrove
wetlands
savannah grassland and a fog desert
you would also need agricultural land
and
a place where you lived and performed
laboratory work
as for your daily routine it would be
rough
keeping yourself alive would be a lot of
work
you'd spend almost 35 percent of your
time
on agriculture then there's all the
maintenance
lab work and household chores
your diet would be mainly vegetarian
it takes at least 25 percent more water
to produce
one kilogram of meat than one kilogram
of wheat
because animals require a lot of
resources
you'd carefully select which ones to
bring into your biosphere
i suggest the african pygmy goat the
most productive domestic
animal in biosphere 2. its milk would be
a welcome break from all the vegetables
you'd be eating
the crew of biosphere 2 survived mostly
on
sweet potatoes and beets but
you'd do a better job and successfully
grow
a hundred different crops including
papaya
and rice even with all your agricultural
work
starvation would be a real threat
because your biome is so small the
slightest problem
can ruin your food crop you could have
unbalanced soil composition from adding
waste
pollinators dying off pests increasing
disease whole fields of food could be
ruined
leaving you very hungry
in the 1991 experiment working
relentless hours and
facing constant hunger created rifts
within the small community
to avoid this you'd need the perfect
number of people to balance the other
work
and food production too few people and
you'd be overworked
too many people and there wouldn't be
enough food to go around
while crops would be a major focus of
your attention
you'd still need to tend to the rest of
the biomes
plants wouldn't just be for eating after
all
they'd also produce oxygen and much like
the
amazon rainforest you'd need areas that
are full of plant life so
you could breathe too little oxygen or
carbon dioxide
and you could be in trouble it's tricky
to balance them
and in biosphere 2 oxygen depletion
became a huge issue why
they mixed too much organic matter into
the soil
this caused an explosion of oxygen
eating microbes which
decreased the amount of oxygen and
the carbon dioxide produced by these
microbes
reacted to a chemical in the biosphere's
concrete
so the plants couldn't use the extra
carbon dioxide during
photosynthesis luckily we learned from
that mistake
you'd make your biosphere so it wouldn't
react to carbon dioxide
okay so you have enough food and oxygen
that's good but
what about waste it has to go somewhere
and
there's no room for landfills in your
mini world
you'd have to compost all human and
animal waste
and remember this compost would increase
the number of oxygen
eating microbes so you'd need to plan
for that while maintaining your
biosphere
everything you use would be reusable
and it would all have to be compostable
you'd mend your clothing made out of
cotton silk and wool
many times then you'd use it for rags
then stuffing and finally you'd throw it
on the compost heap
you'd rely on technology to circulate
air
pump water and constantly measure
everything in the biosphere
this takes power and your only options
would be
solar nuclear or both
earth is a vast complex system where
every living organism including you and
me
are connected recreating that on
any scale is a gargantuan task
and we'll have to master this process if
we ever want to settle mars or
create cities on the moon want to learn
more
about living in a closed biosphere
join us on what if disgust we talked
with jane poynter
one of the original eight members of
biosphere 2.
she'll tell us more about the biology
the oxygen problem
and the psychology of living in a closed
biosphere
[Music]
you